dan jensen um
he's been doing his thing in
costa rica for 35 years
and so his first great biology
and has made a lot of biological
difference but
above that is a whole frame of
of helping a country a whole country
take science seriously take ecotourism
seriously
and make it a part of how it thinks of
itself in the large scale
and no one i know
was doing both practice and theory
around environmental issues in this case
conservation biology
is
as much in the mode of
long-term thinking
most of the environmental action is kind
of an emergency trying to save back to
trying to head off on basis we're trying
to make a bad situation slightly less
bad
and hope for the best
dan does is
basically say good
having done that what about the
next few centuries in millennium
and how do you manage that
and that's what he does better than
anybody
can you possibly kill those two lights
please
now if you could take this statement
and burn it into your conscious
operating
hard drive
we could just go home
because really all i'm going to do today
is say that
now we have had 40 odd 50-yard amount
years
of focus on the losing part
the sort of crisis response that stewart
just mentioned
the barbarians are in the village the
bell is pulling the red flag is up grab
your bow and arrow and
do something to say things now
it's very human response to things going
wrong species going ecosystems are
dropping out the world becoming
contaminated there's too much this
there's too much that that's what all
the focus has been
and what my observation about people is
is that they
they only respond to that
if the village is really being attacked
by their it's all the rest they sort of
become aware you say yeah i know about
that and then they don't do anything
so my focus is on how do you get people
to do something with respect to that
over there and i think it's by screaming
that the world is going to pieces
isn't the way we get people to do things
what i notice is that people hang on to
and develop and invest in and think
about the things that they use that are
useful that's right obviously very
selfish sort of way going at the world
but that's what people do it's homeless
idiot
so my question is not that piece over
there which we already don't know about
everybody's room knows about that part
how do we connect this part here to that
part up there at the top of this slide
in such a matter of that
the remaining wildland pharmacy that
we've still got is still here a thousand
years from now because that's the real
goal
all the rest of it is window dressing
all the rest of it is decorations on the
petticoat it is the real substance is
that that's still with us 1000 years
from now at least that's the goal that i
set out for me and when he sets out for
herself she's sitting out there
somewhere
now when you start talking about this
kind of thing yes we can be theoretical
but very frankly i think one is a lot
more effective and i certainly feel a
lot more effective talking about the
specifics of a place
so we're going to drop into a place
and i don't want to everything i'm
saying tonight is about a place they are
including celestial ronan costa in
northwestern costa rica
if we were talking about angola or kenya
or indonesia or northern australia
the nouns would be different but the
words would be pretty much the same
okay
so here's where we're going it's right
there and to give you some sense of
scale
san francisco and the bay area of
berkeley would sort of fit in that
yellow polygon
this is nicaragua here lake nicaragua
right there
by the costa rica panama and then south
america off there at the bottom of that
drop down to sea level here's the
pacific ocean here the beaches you go
across the flat coastal plain up to the
mountains in the center over the top and
then down into the atlantic on the other
side
drop down at sea level get right down to
it there it is those are the mangroves
in the ocean
get even closer to it here's the macros
we're going to that dry forest behind it
and this is what it looks like close up
now we go inward from there
and this sweeps up an elevation to the
clouds on the top of the ridge here
and a cloudless day up there on top of
that ridge it looks like that and then
we drop down into that forest it looks
like that and we go to the other side
and it rains all the time
in this week we've gone from arizona to
maine to washington
to california
and inside that suite the 50 000 species
of fungi
there are 100 whatever it is a very
large number let's just call it of
insects and spiders and other relatives
there are 960 different kinds of
vertebrates so many of them are little
little things like this mouse and then
there's a few big exotic things like the
spidey porcupine
and then there are people doing things
and what the people are doing in this
case is looking at an interaction which
is right there on the ground
um
it's a large snake lizard for lunch and
that is an interaction
and then if we look closely on the
lizard right
there there's another interaction which
are these ticks
feeding on the lizard and if we look
inside of one of those ticks we find a
new species of
malaria
in other words this is a very large
number of species
and a very diverse set of habitats
carrying out billions of interactions
i just say yourself probably that's
quite a package you know well it's 2.4
percent of the world
uh in terms of species in an area the
size of the greater san francisco and
the bay area
that's also as many species as there are
in all the north american northern new
mexico
wow that's you know that's
pretty hefty for a natural park that's a
really impressive national park with all
those nice things in it
it's wrong
and i don't want you to think that
what i want you to think of it is this
that's 235 000 species of crops
they are not in nice rows they're not
bad they're not the boxes they don't
have levels on them
but there's 235 000 species of crops in
that garden
that's out of the world's 10 million or
so
and of course the question then becomes
is how do we keep these props as i can
for the next stop
this is obviously a made up word
but it refers to our interesting
phenomenon
what are these
these are 9 000 year old spear points
you are sitting
listening to me
like i'm standing in front of a fire a
little village telling you what i just
saw when i went on my little trip today
over the ridge the valley on the other
side came back
you are sitting in the places here you
are sitting here 25 000 years ago
listening to me tell you a story a
member of your village and this is what
i found out we are acting thinking
culturally genetically the same animals
that made these spear points
and since that time we've had gardens
in the very literal sense as part of our
behavior our culture our social
organization our way of doing things so
instead of saying gee how do we get
people to believe in national parks
let's recognize that we have a social
phenomenon already
which encompasses a wild area
all you have to do is change the label
on the wild area so that it becomes by
its label change
then a friendly happy member of our
society and it will still be there then
a thousand years ago as long as there's
a society
one of the crops in this garden now the
first set i'm going to show you are sort
of a whole home you would want to get us
started thinking this way uh if i gave
out little pieces of paper and i said
write down the crops there's a wildland
garden uh that we can
build with you you would come up with
many of these i say that as a partial
apology at the beginning
what is this photograph of
this is so happy to spend 500 a day to
stand on the hot sun taking a picture of
a termite nest
i mean that
i mean this very very literally
what is that say well that's a book for
a bird guy for the birds of costa rica
um
no that's fertilizer
for the inventory's crop and if he
thinks i think that's hyperbole
the ecotourist crop in costa rica
is worth more than the combined coffee
crop banana crop and cattle crop
together
and costa rica is the number two banana
producer in the world
i spend
300 000 of your
tax dollars a year in costa rica
i'm a high yield property
and if you were thinking about costa
rica has nothing more than a garden in
which we are going to grow crops that
have a high sale value creating the
whole thing as a giant biological
station might be actually not an
entirely unsensible thing to do
that school child who earns their
biological educations in the
broadcasting conservation already
because of what i'm casting is looking
very pensively very conservatively at
this
very large very wild snake
when she reaches out and touches it
she's a different person for the rest of
her life
she's beginning to learn how to read
biodiversity
it's converting this thing from a
fearsome object from a roadkill to
something that goes blue in the dark
something bad can be something that's
intelligible something understandable
she doesn't pay in dollar bills at the
front door she pays in votes when she's
22 and 32 and 52 years old
it says up there at the top
the child in us give you the things
which the child and us love remain in
our hearts forever
we all know that
every priest knows it until we fully
conclude
now we all heard about biodiversity
prospecting using the information we
have about species and then putting them
together into um
using tools physical tools to go along
with their information and then putting
them together a bottle full of stuff to
fit us off to the drug world to find
interesting molecules would make an
interesting medicine out of them and um
when um
this kind of when biodiversity
prospecting became organized and
formalized as a kind of industry it was
white because this was going to be one
way they were going to make the world go
along the rainforest to sort of pay for
itself a way of income generating which
will then be used to maintain
reinforcement well in theory and in a
business school you can set that up on a
model pretty well on a blackboard it can
look very nice but the reality is
that
their problems and i'd like to
illustrate the problems with this
what is this
that is the number one
rainforest drug in the world
and it will be probably for a very long
time
if you could put a one penny tax on
every cup of coffee that you make you
could pay all conservation costs and all
related costs as well for all the topics
for all of the world forever
we make three trillion cups of coffee a
year just in the united states
the trick is not finding the rainforest
drug
the trick is not doing the research to
have it work the trick is not getting it
by the fda the trick is getting a one
cent tax on it
and have that one cent tax go on a
bucket debate for conservation there is
no way in hell you could achieve that
so the problem is that you can think of
these things as having value and being
marketable and treatable by
entrepreneurs and all that sort of stuff
but the trick is getting society turn
that penny back
into the system so that you keep
self supporting and making that system
work
as the production of the good if you
like goes on we're going to meet this
problem later on
now what i just described your article
biodiversity services other ones where a
species matters you drink coffee during
some other miscellaneous plant okay
and so on there are also ecosystem
services where collections of species do
things that are useful in one side way
or another now you see this photograph
saying well there's a nice beautiful
volcano with a beautiful cloud on the
top in the middle of the arabic
consortium guanacaste national
park and you open that cloud it looks
like that and if you look closely at the
trees in that you see the water
condensing on the side of the tree here
the water condenses in those clouds up
there runs into this river comes down
there there's pumped out of the river
and feeds costa rica's rice industry
which is a substantial race industry
that's a water factory
and i mean this very literally
the problem of course we have is the
present time now it's not true in
california i understand this but in much
of the tropics that water is a pretty
good one and it just does not then dream
up create a a charge which then feeds
back to keep that forest keeps that
clouds and keeps that water flowing out
of the factory
but it is certainly a good which is a
marketable good and something that could
become part of the long-term continuous
funding of maintaining something like
this conservation area
what is this
a photograph of the train window between
philadelphia and new york this is why
you live in the west coast um and
we all know the problem is there's too
much carbon up there so what's the
solution when you stop putting it up and
you start pulling itself down well
either we've got the ingredients of
course for a crop
this is a a pasture in the middle of the
conservation area this obviously uh uh
in the cadavers here you can see what
used to be in that pasture the cows are
no longer there we buy the land put it
into conservation and we say okay let's
do something with it now well then do
something it consists of what happens
i'm going to just turn around and
photograph in that direction about a
kilometer away and you you grow that
forest back on that pasture you say well
we've restored the forest no you haven't
you've grown 300 tons of carbon per
hectare
you've sucked it out of the air and you
put it back in that fort and also at the
same time you set it up for organs and
hummingbirds and beetles and all the
other stuff which becomes a biodiversity
industry which is the insurance that
keeps the carbon in place
that is the crop like growing corn or
wheater rice
and you can arguably charge more you
know
if the protocols have been signed we
would be charging for it and someday
perhaps we will be charge important the
simple point is it's one more kind of a
crop in a wildland area and as i said
before the all the beasts and creepy
qualities in there can become part of
the insurance it keeps that carbon there
as a forest rather than when you cut
down
now i want to move away from some of
which you would have thought of as
feasible and logical crops to come out
of a conserved wildlife a wildland
garden if you love it's in american
highway five and a half days from here
to chicago
and that's right it's the entrance of
the conservation area you see the sign
over there on the right-hand side
and what the sign says close up uh it's
pretty standard for a sign at the front
door or parked is welcome conservation
area a world heritage site the forest is
the source of life
and development and keep the fire and
don't don't send any fires
uh
obviously there's one hooker in that
time and it's that
this is the only sign on the front door
of a national heart in the world that
has the word development looking into it
it's an easy prediction that five to ten
years from now many will have it because
if they don't they're dead
what do i mean by development well i'll
show you a concrete example
this is the whole area let's say this is
from san francisco to birthday over here
and we're going to drop down in this
area right
there
right on our north boundary
this is the orange juice you have for
breakfast this morning in 1992 all your
little orange trees well maybe in
california you guys actually grow some
of your oranges maybe not only you
anymore you used to um
but
now i think probably most of you don't
and it probably did come from here this
is many many thousands of hectares
competes with brazil for orange juice
production and that's us up there that's
the conservation area there at the top
so here's this and they're there so
obviously they're very close to one
another that's 1992.
uh in 1996 those trees are producing and
these are the first truckloads of
oranges to come out of those out of
those orchards
they go into this giant set of police
machines that eat oranges and pea orange
juice and pulp
and the question is
what then
well here's the you know you take that
orange and you extract the essential oil
from the outside which is worth more
than the juice on the inside and you
bottle it up like this and you sell the
supermarket up here as a biodegradable
cleaner
so what you have is a peel that's had
the essential oils the stuff that burns
your lips when you bite in an orange
taken out
well when this thing cranked up i
talking to the ceo of this thing look i
said what do you do with your orange
fields well in florida we pellet them
and sell them in europe as cattle
feeding those who want to be that costa
ricans because the categories here think
it'll make the milk taste like orange
juice
and um
and so i said
uh would you give me 100 cloves
it said sure where
this is the first time we've seen a
truckload of orange peels being dumped
in the middle of a national park
i bet that one of our 235 000 species of
things would like to eat orange peels so
you're seeing the first truck go down
from the princess there in 1996 there it
is right there with money standing over
here for the witness
and um so we got a hundred truckloads
and spread them out over 400 year old
pastor totally degraded this is an
african grass the yellow stuff you see
in the background colorado
um a totally degraded old pasture and
it's what it looks like six months later
like a parking lot covered with six inch
deep tar
that smells like quantro
and
it was pretty horrible you wouldn't
think about doing that at your national
park uh you know try putting on the
middle of yosemite and see what people's
reaction is right
um and um you think pretty horrible and
it's about a jillian fly larvae and
they're churning
18 months later looks like this there's
not a trace left there's a deep lull
soil on the top
all the grass is gone
dead
and broadly the plants have replaced it
that was the experiment i didn't know
what was going to happen that was the
experiment
and the word crew is this these are fly
larvae that normally feed on fallen
rotten fruit underneath trees in the
forest they come out of the forest on
this giant fruit problem they have to
work and really what they are is like
little plows they're everything this
stuff all the time so the fungi the
bacteria can do their job inside and
that's really the trick to the fire
degradation that takes place
so
i went out and picked out another big
area and now when i'm doing experiments
now we're doing management
pick out a site that's got 23 plant
species most of which are invasive
things from africa and europe
no topsoil left with no forest
regeneration going at all i mean a
disaster okay these are chunks of land
we bought with the concept of restoring
the forest but you look at
how we even started well that's what we
picked out as a site
this is a thousand truck roads
of orange fields in the middle of a
national park
okay
and as you saw before this is the exact
same photograph six months later
after needy
tar
filled with lylar every bird in the
neighborhood is absolutely stuffed with
fly larvae
and uh looks pretty awful
but uh 18 months later it's all gone
and uh
we go ahead four years or where we are
now this is four years ago this is what
you can see this is
2002. and uh we're standing right on the
edge this is the road that goes between
the control on the right and the actual
management area on the left so first i'm
going to turn your photograph that way
and this is exactly what it looked like
when we started you don't change it
there it is just covered with this is an
perhaps all the yellow age stuff there
isn't i'm gonna grasp up this call
i know i'm standing over a car and i
just turn around and take another
photograph that way
there are now 153 species of trees vines
and perennial shrubs in that site so 23
21 whatever it was when we started uh
that's winning for stale she's just a
little you know a meter and a half tall
and um
let's stop this busy going yeah it's of
course you do
on its way
with a deep black little soil inside of
it
so you come down here now and you say
well we'd like to oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
we've got one thing so the question is
how are they going to punch this orange
industry going to pay us now for this
service
well there they are there those are the
older these are the orange trees now
there's all this
here
that's us above that white line
you notice between the white line and
the orange trees are these big chunks of
forests like this there's more orange
trees there in the background as you can
see big chunks of forest what that looks
like from the air
is this so here we are here
the orange is the oranges and these are
the chunks of forest in between so we're
going to well if you like this you can
pay us in chunks of forest
for this service we degrade a thousand
truckloads a year if you pay us every
year it chunks of forest fine
and you get it all set up and here we
are and there's the the minister of
natural resources and the director of
the conservation area and a couple of
technicians the owner of the orange
plantations and the six of five news
there and uh you know the president
signs off on another british ambassador
signs off because they're part of the
money behind this orange operation
you know it's a real deal that you do
and fine
now you come by right now and you say
well i'd like to see what it looks like
now they see your next one it's on
uh i can take you to show you where we
put them down
but there's nothing there they don't
know further
but across the road there's the orange
fields in nice neat rows being turned by
a diesel air conditioner tractor which
is the equivalent or the giant
mechanical fly larva and um
the underneath the plastic tarps are uh
barnes peels with uh
with rice hulls added to it and the
thing is landscape architect with roads
and parts of electricity and the whole
package
very big fancy by liquidation cycle
remember ours is this this is this is us
okay
and that is them
our budget three thousand dollars a year
their budget six hundred thousand
dollars a year our flies we're doing 597
000 worth of work
per year
so why is this thing not functioning
because
us doing this experiment allowed that
competing orange juice company 80
kilometers away to take our orange juice
company to court to the supreme court
for having sully a national park
and they won
so the supreme court says to us you have
to cancel your contract with the
neighborhood orange juice company
now there's more companies and i'm not
going to take the time to go through the
additional complications associated with
them but the bottom line is when you
become industrial when you move out of
the sort of goody goody i'm saying bambi
the deer state and into acting like a
modern farm next to other modern farms
you of course enter the same social
milieu that all the competitive world is
always operating in
and we weren't able to we weren't strong
enough to be able to handle that
and so that while it's technically
biologically extremely feasible it
wasn't politically feasible if you like
try this one okay here we go um
now
when i say my versus development as in
the word desert royal on the entrance to
the conservationary side that's what i'm
talking about so it's just up there with
ecotourism all the other kind of stuff
so why do we go through all this
you know i was just declaring the
national park in the delaware
well the bottom line is maybe this isn't
true in wisconsin or minnesota i grew up
in
but in the rest of the world
if you don't pay your own bills and you
don't do things make yourself a wealthy
member of the society you're not at the
bargaining table when the decisions are
made
and you lose
just like other terrorists they only
have to win once
but homeland security has to win every
time
and we have the same problem
you're thinking this is going to survive
a thousand years
it can't go bankrupt any one of those
thousand years
so you've got to set this thing up in
such a manner that it isn't depending on
the whims of a politician it's not
depending on the whims of congress it's
sometimes on the ups and downs of
silicon valley it's got some kind of
stability it's going to earn its own
income and keep its own keep in the face
of society then you have a chance then
you can stand up and look
the other guy in the eye
and be an equal negotiator across the
table because you're
like yeah
but we're doing all this and we can't
ever afford the left side of it to keep
the biodiversity in the game it is not
an entrepreneurial game like starting a
factory or a company where you can make
yourself real rich retire dump the
company and forget about it
that isn't what we're talking that's not
the game we're in we're acting like that
but that isn't the game where we're in
the game for the long run
that these things are still there
thousands of years so
we're we are being commercial we are
being entrepreneurial but there's this
funny little disclaimer behind it that
isn't necessarily present in normal
human entrepreneurial behavior
so what are the mechanics of it how do
you carry out this what's something we
already talked about but let's get a
little bit deeper
um you need three things you need to
have management the people carrying this
out have to be bioliterate they have to
understand the biology of the scene it's
just like in the old days what you have
for a bank you have to want to be inside
the guy in front with a gun
we don't need a guy with a gun
we need a guy inside who understands it
just like the modern day doesn't have a
guy on the outside with the gun because
there's no money in the bank it's all
out there somewhere invested okay
the second thing we're going to have is
user community who's biology the tourist
the school child the person who's doing
biodegradation all these are things that
the user for this stuff has got to
understand as well or have to be at
least a minimal to understanding
and finally you've got to have the
political freedom to carry this thing
out
that's a very big thing it's a very good
thing and we paid a lot of energy and
time in attaining that political freedom
because we're now talking about taking a
wildland area it's not a passive thing
with a fence around it and a guy with a
gun says stay out
now we're admitting a new member of
society and that means one more person's
feeding trough
and that means that you are then going
to threaten establish political and
economic interests one way or another
so you've got to have somebody some part
of the system has got to be saying yes
green light green light green light go
ahead
we're very aware of that because we just
went through four years in which we
didn't have that um
so what does it look like in actual you
know warm bodies the 100 staff members
roughly 30's 97-100 these are they this
is them this is not some surrogates this
is that is them that is the entire staff
of this operation they're all resident
all
nobody's on the payroll who is the
person
um the uh it's two percent of the
country as a whole 150 300 hectares of
space
and it's 2.4 for the world species so
that's the package that we're thinking
about as
survivor
no bankruptcy
and as a resident administration so i
mean the staff and those administrators
as well as the people who do the other
kinds of work and um this is a float in
the catalans parade
cowboys behind cowboys in front
and we're saying we are farm just like
you are
our daughters marry your sons and your
sons daring our daughters and we shop in
the same grocery stores we go to the
same schools and behind our teachers
teach all your kids basic biology and
fourth and sixth grade
and we produced these people from the
machete swingers and the dishwashers and
the truck drivers and the people who
were doing what you and i think of as a
working class and lower middle jobs in
that agricultural countryside instead of
bringing the people who've been trained
from the outside to spend the money on
training people up through formal
classes like this for these better
taxonomies
or through apprenticeships themselves
attaching somebody literally to somebody
already has been through that process
and then they learn you take them off
the chainsaw and teach them how to raise
caterpillars and plastic bags
and you produce the next generation this
is not a setup this is real this is
that's the fair taxonos that is not her
daughter that's somebody else's daughter
playing and putting leaves and bags
but what is she doing she is seeing
adults carry out a respectable job and
pick on a real paycheck for doing an
honorable kind of thing called
biodiversity management instead of all
the other things that are role models in
the system and out of 500 of those kids
you'll get the next ministers or
professors of biology
now what does it really cost to do this
you know in hard dollars okay um
so we started this whole thing a wee
that's a big week but it started in 1990
in 1966 as a little national monument
and the
cost of this time has been 48 million
dollars in total
on a per hectare basis 314 on the first
species basis is 200 and i've heard that
the four ecosystems on that is 12
million
that's what it actually might have buy
it off the shelf that's the kind of
money you would have to have
raised to make this so that they happen
the 7 500 donors a number of this room
uh and then of course there's been
earned income but one source for another
indicated the front door and all that
sort of stuff
the cost to finish this thing forever by
forever i mean
quite literally
to keep this thing now self-organized
self-running self-feeding system
indefinitely
for this kind of size staff i'm not
saying you couldn't have more but for a
minimal functional height my qualified
staff
is we're looking at another
basically uh 16 million dollars
that's that's what it's going to cost
and frankly that's what i'm trying to
raise the money for that piece of paper
you got out there and the other details
where to send your checks um
yeah in all seriousness that's the kind
of money has to be put together one big
check or a whole lot of little checks
to finish this thing so that it's still
there a thousand years from now
so all the rest of the machine is
enclosed
now what i want to do
you've seen now and in this whatever
it's been 35 minutes or so
a um
sort of a smartest board of different
activities that have taken place over
the last 15 years in the sort of
development of putting together this
thing
and each of those things in there the
fire control a pair of autonomous the
biological education program each of
those different things has had a start
and then grown and exploded out of that
and i want to now present one start and
explosion that's taking place literally
right now in the system i don't have a
new explosion that's coming out of this
thing and it relates to the sword up
there called inventory which is setting
up all those 235 000 species so
everybody can use them any way they want
the um uh inventory as i mean it in this
sentence
is put a name on it figure out where it
is figure out something about what it
does and have a set of rules to get it
when you want if i get it i mean take a
photograph of it or take a sample of it
or whatever it happens to be and then of
course put it on the internet that's
what i mean for the 235 thousand pieces
when i say inventory 250 000 pieces now
this was a year ago
i would have gone through some of the
things i'm going to show you first but
this is not a year ago this is now and
you've got a transformation in my
understanding of where we are
technically in the world and what
options are now available to carry this
whole giant step through
and
it looks like this that's the basic loop
you know you find the bug out there you
put him in on a table you take pictures
of him you got information about him you
put him into the into a computer it goes
out to somebody's head 255 000 times
that that's what we're we're talking
about as a basic process and of course
it produces huge blocks of data with
collateral information stuck on
specimens and sequences and photographs
and all those private videos
now that might sound like science
fiction that's going on right now we're
not talking about we're not there ain't
new yet here this is still there it's
right here in my laptop computer
and other people's and you go on our
website and you can put a main head and
you can get information and you say well
we've got a species page you want one of
those 235 000 species it's really the
same thing on the web it is just taking
ripping the page out of the steel bike
and uh so far we're still on the russian
video ground and given that in the
species page it looks like that
and it's got a date it's got an author
it's frozen in time it's just again this
is like a page on a field guide and it's
a lot of work
okay but you can do it with an older
wheel let's be invented for this
now people to me that i'm going to
confront him with a lot of work things
start thinking about how do we do this
on the fly extracting information from
databases and putting it out there
instead of handwritings or pages and
field guides
and they're pretty straightforward as
well this is again normal wheel that has
to be described you type in autonomous
at their website uh and you get all the
ones from costa rica they go there they
are i mean that's just pulled out of the
database now that's not a hard
hard hardwired thing uh and you say
whoops there's an awful lot of them i
want to prepare this one in my hand with
it so i'm in the dry forest so you go
into the same thing and you type in dry
forest as well as the genus of cars and
bingo you got the species that are
burning right for it makes it easier to
compare with the one you've got in your
hand so again we're still on comfortable
ground there
and you can even ask what does this
thing eat and there's all the
information about it just right this
right now you know get on your desktop
off the server and fill it up no problem
or screen
you're just using a yellow pages
it's the same thing we've been doing for
a long time except now we do it through
google and we do it on our website
what we've all forgotten is that when
you open the pages here you look at
mandarin restaurants and you pick out
the one that says super hot and you call
that one up and say it's all your food's
super hot and they said oh yes and then
you make a reservation to go to dinner
at that point which we've all forgotten
what you really used the yellow pages
for was to get that telephone number
you look up mandarin restaurant and you
just automatically pluck the phone
number off with it
what's the phone number for those 235 to
be keyed
here's the problem
we have literally
a hundred thousand years or more of
learning biodiversity as a society or as
certain members of the shaman the hunter
the certain individuals the
old grandma making tea for the sick kid
we've learned a lot about earth and
we've forgotten a lot about biodiversity
and there's this package of knowledge
that sort of circulates it's getting
bigger and bigger and bigger the
computer just gets huge
and there's you
right here
and right now you want to know what that
frog is
because he stuck his finger in my eye
and should i worry or shouldn't die
the first scientific paper i wrote in
1963 was about this species not stupid
another very similar species of fraud
then i stuck my finger on and stuck my
finger in my eye and i thought my eye
was dead
okay
this is you at that moment you want to
know its telephone number
so that you can go to google and put it
in and learn what we know about that
frog
and you can't because you can't get his
telephone number there are 15 people in
the world who can give you the telephone
number for that frog but they're not
standing there next to you with the rain
at three o'clock in the morning in
costa rica
they're
la county museum or in the smithsonian
institution or where it happens to be
and yeah there's a book as big as a
tunnel directly it allows you to key it
out but you're not carrying one in your
backpack
and you don't know all those funny words
need either
and now there's a hundred there's 10
million of them out there how are you
going to connect one of those 10 million
names to this rock so you can get to
there
that's where the problem is
and we've all forgotten that problem i
forgot everybody's forgotten
sorry
we
automatically think aha we now have
google we now the internet now we have
databases so we can make the connection
right here from this
to here no problem but you've forgotten
in order to make that work there you've
got to have the telephone number that
goes at this point
so how are you going to make the link
well there's the jargon word
it's an obviously invented word it may
actually become quite familiar or some
substitute for it might come and what
are we really talking about
well let's do it this way here you are
in your spaceship and you're landing
and you're going to land right there in
the acv
you look out the window your spaceship
and very literally you're looking at 100
000 species and i mean this literally
that's not hyperbole that's a photograph
in the middle of the acg
look out the window
and there's a hundred thousand species
in that photograph
you step out of your spaceship
into this forest there's three four
hundred of them staring in the face
right there in front of you
everyone has had a name telephone number
for the last 50 to 150 200 years
and you can't put it on any of them
me i've spent 35 years of my life in
this course i can identify around 10 of
what's in that program
yes there are two or three people in the
world who if they were standing right
there could in fact make me name 30
now you can collect it and send it to
the national museum or to mdl and get a
name six months from now
that is what you need the name you need
the name now and you're trying to do
something with one of those things now
in the field right now you're going to
collect a sample they just bit you you
just ate it it's one of your
caterpillars is eating it you're an
intensely interested ecotourist i don't
care what your reasons are
you need to know the name now for this
for this or this or this and you can't
do it i don't care how much knowledge
there is in that monastery on the top of
the hill
i had a lot of the forest 300 to 500
species of moss sitting on this sheet i
can identify every single one of them
and i'm one of maybe three people in the
world who can and if this is your light
i'm not going to be standing here by
your side to help you know what this is
and this is this is this is if you want
to sample all of them you want to do
something with them or you want to
collect the leader up and send them out
to work and see if they've got an
interesting drug in order
you're stuck
you can't read nature the whole damn
world is blind
it's effectively bio illiterate yes
there are this 0.0001 of us as priests
who can read a little tiny fraction of
this
but the rest of the world
is delivered
that's the solution
a gadget
you buy for nothing or it's given away
for free
you carry your back pocket like a comb
something like that
we could put
the telephone numbers for 30 million
species in a chip the size of my little
fingernail
crust
take a leg off the button stick a leg in
the gadget
one minute later one sequence
one telephone number
get it
fired radio shack okay
that is where the solution lies
and i would argue that is what's going
to keep these things alive in the long
run is allowing people to view the
forest as a library full of readable
books because at the present time it's
like a person who's illiterate looks at
a library is nothing but a lot of nice
firewood stacked on shelves
the idea came from the sky over here
polly bear is a canadian professor of
molecular biology and member genetics
who said hey instead of worrying about
the whole genome of things
let's worry about how little a piece of
genome can we extract and get a unique
signature
it turns out it's real small
the idea of course is analog an analogy
with a barcode on a can of any
supermarket or the barcode on a specimen
in a museum like this thing down here in
other words read a piece of the dna
sequence as if it were a marker
and then of course there's these
immediately calling a barcoder and
jargon and barcoding
for this kind of stuff that i'm talking
about what gene this is a mitochondrial
gene an animal called cytochrome oxidase
one co1 and you take this little piece
right here which is 1500 base pairs long
and take slice a little piece out of
that
there's enough information in 300 to 600
of those 1500 base
pairs in the world apart
technology's real so
plastic tube i'll label it take a leg
off drop it in the tube fed exit
the
in canada a couple hours later for 10
bucks you have a name
think about that for a moment next time
you've got a beetle in your backyard is
eating your rosebush you want to know
what it is you think how much money and
private ever it takes to get people in
sacramento or the people in
the smithsonian excuse me in beltsville
to give you a name that you can plug
into google to figure out what they were
doing
and this is just starting now
this is what all those sequences
actually looks like here's the base
pairs along here like this a c c g g t
like that and that's the signature i'm
talking about just takes a small piece
of that sequence to tell these things
apart
so it doesn't work these are the bats
in southeast asia
the length of this line
is how different
this little set of three individuals in
this species are from this set of
individuals the four individuals of that
species are so that's a two percent
scale up there so here's two percent
four percent eight six eight ten and
twelve so this set of species is twelve
percent different from that set of
species on that little sequence you can
tell all the species of bats so some of
these are apart but nothing but a little
piece of skin
the birds of north america same thing
there are about two percent which are
confusable even plumbers that run up
down the beach that you can't tell apart
about 16 other ways as well some of
those are confusable they're only one or
two percent different amongst them but
the vast majority you can tell you know
pull a feather out of an airplane
turbine you know immediately what it is
this saturday in laws close to evening
now notice that the whole bachelors are
all the same right here those are all
it's individuals of the same species
from different parts of this group
just give me a leg
for hundreds of species of leftover
for 10 bucks a couple hours i could tell
you what species it was
it sounded like magic that sounds like
science fiction and it was science
fiction it's not even boring
now granted we don't have to use
sequences to identify everything i mean
well what a bird book is you see we
don't have to have a feather on the bald
eagle i know it's a bald eagle
you think okay and you just wait a
minute
i mean you know these are my lip peppers
i don't have to have but there's nothing
else in the world it's like a white lip
pepper so there's no problem you don't
have to get a piece but what if you're
looking at a piece of jaguar and
you want to know what it ate
you get two hairs off one of these guys
in the general warship put it through a
sequencer haha and ate lip backery
now when he gets out of things that
don't look so distinctive his peccaries
do say like this genus of commerce say
well haven't you give me that and then
give me the water whatever i can pick
out the one that it belongs to no
problem
would you have guessed that this and
this are the same species would you have
guessed that this and this are the same
species would you have guessed that that
yellow that pink thing there is the same
as this yellow thing over here no you
wouldn't but the sequence is a little
probably immediately
so like well okay okay okay there's some
nice cases but really you know most
butterflies look like different
butterflies look like butterflies
uh-huh how many of them are in that 40
tell me how many species there are
there are only three people in the world
me being one of them and these all live
in my backyard in costa rica
and this genus there i don't know what
it is it's 300 or 200 something enormous
number species don't look just like this
from argentina to mexico you can know
all of our secrets
now
just to show you how dramatic this sort
of stuff can be in a bald eagle example
i mentioned a moment ago this is a very
common butterfly everybody knows central
america
south texas to argentina my turn you're
losing butterfly net in panama canal
zone now
for half an hour
well there's 200 people in this room 100
of you'll come back with one of these
things everywhere this is the guard from
the roadside thing this is all flowers
everybody has had a name for 225 years
this traffic is prograded museums are
full of them drawers
totally boring conditioning about
one thing
this is a box full of them
mounted upside down so you can see what
the underside looks like
and there they are you know
whatever
uh-huh
you sequence that box actually 460 of
them
out of that box from one place
you got a messy concentration room
there are
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten species in that box
all hiding in one day for 225 years
one of the best known widespread
butterflies that's why me telling you
that there's twelve species of whole
vegans
now i'm not saying there are tall
species of baltimores i'm simply saying
that this hit from everybody
now you say oh no those are
polymorphisms so these are just genetic
groups and that those aren't species for
heaven's sakes
we take them and line them up to what
the caterpillars look like for each of
those groups
and the animals are dead on identical
the caterpillars obviously are different
and they eat different food
this species goes from south texas to
argentina you tell me how many species
of the strawberries one greater they
really are and you get 10 of them in one
place
now to make to do this kind of magic
what do you really need we need a global
sequence library something that allows
us to we get the sequence from the
button and you compare the sequence
against the library of sequences to know
which one it was where are we going to
get the blender turns out what are
museums now i've grown up all my life
think of these depositories from
specimens that we study and work with
all of the references for a lot of stuff
and things it never crossed my mind
did you build a course like that that
labeled that sequence out of all those
pickled and dried specimens sitting here
you don't have to have them frozen at
minus 70 degrees pickled and absolute
alcohol treated this way just ordinary
old museum specimens just go down the
shelf chip chip chip chip chip like that
and build your sequence library and in
fact the big museums are now starting
this literally as we speak
two weeks ago the sloan foundation in
new york should put six hundred thousand
dollar brand into the smithsonian
institution to set up a secretariat to
carry out this process not to fund the
process but to carry that make sure it
happens with workshops
community people doing facilitating and
all that kind of stuff to build that
library up there so that when you get
this thing in your backyard
you have something to compare it with
and you say well wait a minute there's
10 million species out there you only
describe the minimum yeah but you know
what
99 of the species you will deal with in
your life and all the kinds of things
you might do in the world already
sitting on a museum shelf somewhere but
we just get that set into a sequence
number and then bill the rest of it as
time goes on
the second thing we need is to
miniaturize
what is sitting in paul and bear's lab
and a jillion other molecular biology
labs around around the world now
the machinery that you use to do the
sequencing right now is two tabletops
worth that half a technician
in other words how do you take that and
squeeze it down into something the size
of my home
that's technically doable it's just
intended
but that has to happen that
miniaturization process has to happen to
get the gadget that everybody has the
6.2 billion people are carrying the back
pocket like a cone so the one time a
week the one time a month when violence
actually matters they could read
violence
and you say oh who cares
who cares about identifying all those
prices color beetles and all the little
slugs and all that kind of stuff you
don't care when your four-year-old
daughter needs one
you will be very concerned at that
moment when you put your hand down and
then stings you and your hand starts to
swell up and you wonder am i going to
die or do i just go to god
at the moment it's eating the tree in
your backyard
at the moment you think it's an invasive
species of infant introduced from russia
by a bioterrorist at that moment you
will care very much
so there's it's like reading when we
teach you to read it at the third grade
in second grade it isn't because you're
going to turn into shakespeare
it's because now and then you're going
to want to read a newspaper or write a
legal document or write a letter or use
your laptop or something like that we
don't know when or how but we can bet
you will
and furthermore people say well who
cares about biodiversity well if you
went out in the field of farmer's field
in 11th century and you asked somebody
clown in the field and you want to know
how to read and say why
what could it be to read mine what would
i do with that that's what those monks
up there and monster on top of hillary
didn't do me any good
he wasn't envisioning newspapers and
legal documents and books and internet
and all that other stuff that we use
reading and writing for
and finally there's got to be a toll
booth
either directly or indirectly or the
combination as we have out there in the
world today
every time you identify a beetle or a
plant or a weed or whatever it happens
to be and you have aha this is the thing
from mongolia that's only been invading
california and i was going to call it a
horrible problem unless we kill it right
now
every time you stick that thing in there
and identify that plant i want a penny
to drop in a bucket
and that bucket is used then
to fund the process that creates the
information that you get when you type
that name into google or it's equipment
otherwise what's the good of having a
fantastic telephone directory
with good telephones and good telephone
numbers every time you call you get
nothing
okay something's gotta fund the process
that's gonna take the information you
already have put it in a usable format
and add more information to it instead
you can see how it's been going
self-feeding system okay but it's got to
be a total and that's not me that's some
entrepreneurial type you can think it
understands that part of the world and
builds that into the system remember the
cup of coffee
we could pay every single conservation
cost in the world if you can put a one
cent tax on it if they've got a one cent
tax built into the cup of coffee from
the mechanic
you can hopefully
and of course it has to be someone to
call
that's what you get from the public
now
close this off very quickly here
what i'm calling and i've been talking
to you about the last say 10 or 12
minutes is what i call bioliteracy the
ability to read biodiversity and i think
the relationship of viral literacy to
the relationship between wild wild
university and people
is going to go and can go the same way
that literacy has been among people
like i say the 11th century reading and
writing who cares
of our quarters the gadget is
democratization of violence it allows
everybody to emily sit here in the front
row
grandpa
to the entrepreneur and for work
to know what the beast is
that they've gotten
what they want
i think it's analogous to these things
freddie press modeling toward the kodak
camera cell phones the wright brothers
airplanes that's a tall word what do i
mean it's analysis what i mean is each
one of those was a cheap thing made for
common people
with the concept that everybody will
handle and they took off and they
produced polynomials
what they simply produced
so at the beginning i said while in
bible receipt you can
use it or lose it
that can be translated
if you read it
or because if you can read it
you will use it
and i'd like to close with this
people say
look you work in costa rica it's a
harvest place that's my army everybody's
educated it's healthy it's very friendly
it's all those things whatever
everything you do is rolling
because you've got this nice little
cocoon in which you can carry out the
guanacasti conservation area the
audiobook housing so you can flour and
blossom and being entrepreneurial and
self-contained and teach people and hire
locals and be resident owned all that
kind of stuff
and that's irrelevant
because you know you can't do that in
venezuela angola thailand
you name it across all the disaster
cases across the world my argument is
this
the wright brothers
did not
pick a blizzard in january
in minnesota to try to fly their first
airplane
their goal is to show that you can go
300 feet without killing yourself
once somebody did that
and did it repeatedly
the rest of society took that and filled
it
what we're talking about here
is the wright brothers eric thank you
very much
next month the second friday
um we will be back very fortunate but
over the conference center with david
rumsey
uh he's done magical things with matt's
become one of those great collectors of
american mass
and has technologically figured out how
to make them plentiful and flexible
through time
and it's called mapping time it'll be
amazing
unfortunately
one of dan's friends came up with a
question before the time
this is from ridge bennell you're
uh here i'll call your name just stand
up so we can see
the question
there he is okay
he says
does all this fundraising stop
interfere with your entomological
research
and is it worth it to you
this is not actually a plan of question
this guy is obnoxious and he asks for
these kind of questions each time on
medium okay so it's it's i didn't know
what it was going to be but i think
there would be one of those questions um
back in 1985
and 86 when we had embarked on this sort
of thing we were just hardcore ivory
towers everybody in this room and for us
the forest was a nice place that we went
through and did our stuff in and that
was somebody else's concern to do this
kind of stuff
and i won't
spend a half an hour going through the
process that made the transformation but
as part of the transformation we found
ourselves standing in a big meeting in
the u.n a little bit
and it just sort of hit me between the
eyes
and i found myself saying to all these
well-dressed people at tables with
crystal and water tables and so on
look we have spent 35 years of our eyes
creating a stack of
literature if you like about science
this thick
350 odd publications
and we could take the next 35 years of
our life and do it again
and all the things that we're
encapsulating in this stack of
literature will be there
this becomes an archival historical
document describing what was
or we can make the active decision
to basically stop 90 of that
and do what this this project if you
like that we have been describing up
here for the last hour along with a
whole bunch of other people
and we decided at that point uh that we
just made the decision in a very
explicit way we dumped 90 percent of our
research when he put her finishing up
her phd on call waited we had a
political election with costa rica we
couldn't do anything and finished her
thesis at that time but we just said
okay yes
this is going into a huge chunk of what
we love doing but yes it is more
important
because the nature conservancy and the
world wildlife fund and unesco and the
fish and wildlife service with the
national park service and all the other
people who do this as a career as a
profession
it's not enough
we have to get out of that every tower
and let's start with the campaign speech
but it's not meant to be one we have to
get eye on their retirement and join
forces with that process that they're in
that's what we did totally not knowing
anything other than we had to do it
because otherwise we're in this
ridiculous situation where we're going
to spend the rest of our lives doing
another gorgeous set of papers and
winning awards and being applauded and
all this kind of stuff
as we have been
that's all there's nothing there anymore
so what you need if you're being
hardcore economist on it you can say to
yourself you know
put your time into making it live
forever and then think about all the
other people who are going to then study
and do things with it and what they will
produce will be fascinating
fastly fascinating than one we can do
ourselves just the two of us in the next
35 years
so that's the answer to richard's
question
yes it does interfere but we don't think
about it if everything is a trailer you
do one underneath the other and this was
in fact working and we still feel now
today even though we get a little
depressed in the middle of this curve it
is
brian fisher
what examples exist
that demonstrate that increased use
results in increased conservation
all the cases that i mentioned up here
the orange peels the turrets the
children the researchers that's all use
in my terminology
and being able to walk into a wildland
area and read everything that's there
that's use it these footprints but
that's used
so you ask what well just to start off
with the 48 million dollars that is
taken to build this conservation area
and protect the block of species equal
to all of north america he's all created
by that use
without that news this wouldn't exist
so that's the first time it's a concrete
product
it costs 48 million dollars you can
put it right now on a per species basis
i can't remember the numbers anymore and
i figured but they're in the handout
that you've got
uh but you know he's i'm gonna buy it
off the shelf you can put a price tag on
it that use is what gives you the money
to do
because that money would never come
forth as just protect this asset
i'll put a fence around it and there it
is
so i would say to brian that the use is
all the things you do there and we have
a concrete case of it right here and i
think this container concrete case
exists already in some small why do you
have yellowstone and grand canyon and
the great smokies and yosemite still
because if you lose them
you may not like all those tourists in
the university but you take those
tourists away and you will lose this
energy
you may not like eight and a half
million people going through great smoky
mountains every year there's a big
hungary right through the middle of it a
huge tourist juice you take that away
you won't have this locust in 50 years
you take the people out of yellowstone
you all have yellowstone in 50 years
now up here we do different kinds of use
than in other cultures and different
cultures are going to use it in
different ways that's certainly true
it has to beat that culture but i would
argue that that use is necessary by a
very unbashful website i'll pay five
percent to keep 95 percent sure i'd like
to have a park with no roads in it no
american highway running through the
middle of it no power lines and no
tourists and all that i'd love to have
another biologist i'm
delighted with wilderness areas
maybe once you walk
society isn't going to give it to you
but the other thing is that we're all
sucked into this thing of thinking of
wilderness there is no wilderness in the
world we need to talk about the old
world there is none here we lost
wilderness 9500 years ago
first wave of the first wave of human
hunters that went through here took out
all our megaphones from that point on we
are severely impacted from the beginning
so there is no wilderness there is just
a certain kind of weapons
so that five percent that you lose with
the footprints of the users and all that
kind of stuff
hey that's just one more kind of insult
that we want to add to all the other
insults that are already there
permanently
you're never going to get your ground
sauce back you know we're going to get
your dolphin there's and put the nuts
back
and all the things they did remember
there were animals walking around here
that weighed twice what an african
relative was right here
they're still down in the library of
targets
our people took them out
it's like going to east africa
machine-gunning elements no different at
all
so i would argue that the us that we now
do
is what's keeping our wildling areas in
the game and if we don't jack up the use
like i'm talking about here to be a
diverse portfolio of
you're still going to lose the
department table
but the only thing yo somebody's got to
offer for it is it's a pretty place to
have your picnic you are going to lose
it someday i'll make that as a wildlife
prediction
like i said
with terrorists they only have to win
once
and you've got only every single time
and that's a no inhibitor
a couple kind of technical questions on
the uh
approach
the cli gene this is an anonymous
question
uh was chosen how was the cli gene
chosen it's the best to be used for the
barcoder and someone also asked what
would you find this is ralph walker
uh what would you find if you put human
samples in the coi test not the very
sorry
i asked the last one first we're not
very diverse
on co1 we all fall out pretty much
apparently uh
you go to gene bank and get human
samples it turns out that we are pretty
much all one animal
but that at that level you're just like
blue jays or some other thing that just
is basically one monomorphic population
not to say there isn't genetic
differences across populations of humans
of course there is but on the co1 on co1
why i should have explained maybe is
that co1 in your mitochondria is what
handles your oxygen respiration
works like everybody who breathes oxygen
has the same gene
um now how is the cr1 gene chosen it was
done arbitrarily the best of my
knowledge my understanding it was it was
done fairly well because there are other
genes you could have used as well the
trick was to make it
to try to get that sequence from
everybody from my urban species sorry
from many many many species rather than
use just gene for that one and this
other gene from this one another gene
for that one now your gadget's got to be
able to read three or four or five or
seven genes
so it needed to be one gene that you get
the sequence from everybody all the
different species on and the second
thing is it's very common gene and your
mitochondria you have multiple multiple
multiple multiple copies of your
mitochondria in every cell in your body
here
whereas nuclear genes that are the
nucleus of your cell there's just one
problem
in the center of each cell so you're
limited by the but you have trillions of
amino acids so we'll make the money out
of you or we pull a hair off take a
little piece of skin
there's jillian copies of the signal so
it makes it easy to get the copy to read
out of it
now that's true for other mitochondrial
genes also and since other genes could
have been used the point was to pick one
of them and just a little piece of one
of them and try to get that from
everyone
as opposed to trying to get the whole
genome
of course which takes a lot more money a
lot more time a lot more sampling and so
on and you could do the same thing if we
had the whole genome for every species
you could do it with that but you still
only take a little piece for a telephone
number you don't need the social
security number and all your credit card
numbers and your street address number
and all those other things so no it's
you
just one of those numbers is it not
if you're using a piece of receipt
that's
okay here's some questions you're going
to probe a little deeper into the use
question first from michael kramis
what do you think of the tendency to
patent nature
and ask one
repeat question from last night
we talked
what do you think about genetically
modified organisms
and how they play out both in terms
ecologically and in terms of use
those are two very different questions
uh let's start with the first one the
patented one
um
frankly it's very far outside of my area
of knowledge uh i would say that
patenting is a human artifact this is
something it's a process that we invent
uh as part of our
society and entrepreneurial structure
and um i'm certainly not
social as a sociologist i'm certainly
nowhere near enough knowledge to
to speak about that like i can speak
about the stuff i was talking about up
here
so i'll waffle off of that question and
say that
i don't have enough understanding and
knowledge to have a considerate
considered answer to the question of
patenting the process of not happening
gene sequences and related
whole organisms and varieties i can see
the logic presented by many people for
patenting varieties of tomatoes and
cotton and so on so i can see the logic
in that just like any other intention of
any other machine
when you get down to having things that
occur already in nature
i have the same queasiness that you do
but i don't have enough knowledge
in that area to have a
consideration
the second one is nor the question of
gmos genetically modified organisms
i let many biologists come at this from
a historical background of course that
all of society is built on gmos and has
for a very long time it's just that
those gmos were accumulated over a long
period of time through many many
experiments by a slow process
and done shall we say
in manners that mimic the natural
process of speciation and for iodine
development uh is just done by some
indian grandmother or some clever shaman
we notice that if you cross this with
this you get the following thing and
we've been building gmos for a very very
long time now we're suddenly building
them very fast
and we're building them with odd
combinations or potentially odd
combinations that we
uh that are very we believe are rarely
encountered in nature they do occur did
occur in nature but rarely now we have
the potential to produce them much more
rapidly
and so now we get in a very obviously a
very sticky very difficult thing because
we are a position where we could produce
organisms which
are extremely extreme nuisances or more
substances from the standpoint of
invasive species you must have disease
organisms
that's all true
uh case by case basis uh
on the sink i don't think we can stop
them being produced
i don't think humans are willing to stop
themselves let's put it that way
so that i think the question becomes of
what kinds of regulations are we willing
to accept in our society to have gmos
appear in a more orderly manner under
more controlled circumstances and i'm
not the person who is well-versed in
this entire set of law and the
international treaties and all the other
stuff that we've built with that to have
them to stand up here and give you an
our lecture on it
share the queasiness about it but at the
same time i also am not as bothered
about as a biologist i'm not bothered
about it as say some people are for whom
biology is a little more magical is a
little a little less
nuts and bolts kind of thing as it is as
to somebody like me
uh so i'm not perhaps as worried about
gmos as some people are but i said they
wouldn't write them off because i'm
gonna think about two things i think
they do i don't think about that but i
don't have a sort of immediate cut
reaction
but we have to have them to solve the
the major food problem in the
undeveloped countries the great
starvation problem that is nonsense we
already produce enough food to feed the
whole world without a problem we have a
willingness to distribute
okay which is very very different than a
production problem
and if you start making twice as much
rice or twice as much coffee or twice as
many peaches or whatever it has to be
that will solve this distribution
product
so in a certain sense it's kind of crazy
because we say well if any of you just
make twice as much food anyone have a
food problem it doesn't work that way it
doesn't work that way the green
revolution that i went through as a
young man hearing all about that was
going to solve all the world's problems
of course it solved none of them because
all we did was make another set of
people big enough to eat all the real
extra rice that was produced and came
along with a host of other problems
along with it
so that major thing that's always put
out there is the gmo reason for doing
things i frankly don't find a very
convincing reasonable call
stephen hill
how do you explain the relatively
enlightened attitude in costa rica to
conservation ecology biomanagement and
so on and i might add how does one get
many costa ricans happening
here
let's go one there's two of those two
questions again costa rica itself is
actually
well any country is complicated foreign
cities but there's a central aspect of
costa rica that's missed by a lot of
people
spain colonized the world spain portugal
colonized the new world pretty
thoroughly at a certain time right
and it was mexico guatemala
excuse me mexico guatemala bogota
lima they're the big centers of of
colonization
and when you have guatemala as the
center and you go south of guatemala you
get costa rica sort of the outback and
the most all possible sense of outback
it's like the north scope of alaska it's
as far from anything as it could
possibly be and in fact spain throughout
costa rica at one point in its history
literally said we hereby disown you
you're not even a colony anymore it
doesn't somebody else took it from spain
it's that you don't exist and costa rica
got on his knees and crawled to
guatemala city and begged please take us
back
they did
and the point is that costa rica sat
there as a whole of the spanish empire
and right about the time of the end of
the civil war between about then and
1920 europe discovered this hole
and there were masses of immigrants from
italy france belgium denmark
england germany the whole package into
costa rica so you've got
post-revolution europe
culture coming as a wave into a hole in
the spanish empire
and the culture you meet in costa rica
today is this incredible hybrid it's so
like all the people who came off the
boat in the elvis island
except they went into costa rica as a
whole and so it's still spanish the king
and it's it's a chemist calling but it
got these ways of other things
that is all part of the high education
level to throw away the army level the
social security level the high uh health
circuit all those kinds of things the
second thing is that costa rica have
been educated in a very nice way from
what they call the peace benefit they
dump their army
on all the money it went into the air
would
national budget here all the money would
have gone in the army with the
universities
so you you flipped instead of buying
taxes guns you you paid poorly paid
professors okay so
what that
they're very proud of the educational
system that that created
so that's the second sort of loop in
costa rica
the third thing is
i'm not very careful about how to say
this because it can come across majority
but i mean more descriptive
it's a nation of small businessmen
everyone is a small businessman it goes
through
so it runs the country on a
businessman's mindset
and all the level of conservation in
costa rica is pure economics
i mean that very literally if the green
belt which is 25 percent of costa rica
wasn't generating
what coaster it could use as economic
resources
it'd be falling in 20 years
very very literally it is not that costa
rica is a nation of tree hunters
it is a nation that unconsciously and
many times over the year and no
understanding of why
found itself with a marketable object
called the green
and that marketable object and i wasn't
joking when i said the tourist crop is
worth flora
the banana crop the coffee crop and the
cattle crop all put together
and
that doesn't escape a small any a man
whose mindset is running the local
grocery store
understands that immediately
and will vote for anything
when i first when when i first started
this we were trying to learn what
ministers are what governments are what
banks are
as we talked to these people a lot and
the the president of the president of
the central bank the top
policy money maker in the country
said to us very literally i'll do
anything to keep the tourists in the
country one more day
well that means opening the national
park putting the road through here
putting the building over there
decreeing this to the national park
where people come and see and watch the
turtles and eating the restaurant and
stay in the hotels the process i'll do
it
this is not that he loves turtles
but he can recognize that that is a
resource they can sell
costa rica sells it
i don't say this dude well i didn't say
that i gotta get out competed by cancun
and peru and ecuador but remember the
peace benefit for a long time one of the
competitive advantages was you could go
to coast street without being afraid of
being kidnapped or shot or all the other
stuff that was happening in latin
america costa rica is now losing that
competitive advantage and they're very
very worried about it okay
now the other question how do you get
more costa ricas i don't think you're
getting more costa ricans i think what
you do is
i would argue that the general
ingredients that i'm talking about up
here vis-a-vis the wildlife area of
making an economically welcome and
sociologically welcome piece of the
society i think you can do that in any
country
i work all over the tropics extensively
for a long time
i'm confident that we could have done
this kind of thing in veracruz mexico we
could have done this in venezuela we
could have done this and although we
could have done this in cambodia or
thailand granted a world a big war comes
through that's of course that's a
rolling rock that trashes everything but
leaving aside those kinds of major
perturbations
you could implant this kind of attitude
and it is being implanted
in other places as well
it could be implanted it is being
inflamed
but it requires you to decide you want
to go that way as opposed to the put the
barbed wire fencer on and right around
on the submachine gun away which is the
other the cops and robert's way of
dealing with conservation which is at
very limited costa rica went through
that stage as well
bart guards carrying the carbines the
whole passage when we arrived and this
thing here there were 22 park guards
parked guards on their horses with guns
riding around playing props and robbers
with the poachers and the tree cutters
and the burners
we said we hear my kid all those
positions back to the car
when i'll go out and raise the money to
hire staff and we'll teach the staff to
do something specific
you'll be a school teacher or an
accountant or do research or grow trees
or be police we have eight police
two percent of the country you know the
tough guys with dark glasses the big gun
and the radios and out there two o'clock
in the morning running a roadblock on
the inter-american highway they're there
that like police
and they do
get people who break laws as opposed to
us are the cops and robbers like you saw
on atomics tv
and uh
that attitude can be implanted anywhere
i i don't see any reason
but it requires you decide to do it
now brian fisher said now he has one of
these questions he's sitting here
somewhere he's taking on madagascar at
the early stage where we were when we
were 40 years old
and what it has to do is somebody say
okay
i'm going to do that and now i'm going
to win a prize by suggesting a new idea
for venezuela and then go to colombia
and suggest a new idea for colombia and
then i'm going to go to peru and suggest
a new idea for peru